en el vídeo sobre hibridación sp3 vimos
que un carbono estaba unido a cuatro
átomos mientras que en el vídeo de
hibridación sp2 vimos que el carbono
estaba unido a tres átomos ahora en este
vídeo vamos a fijarnos en el tipo de
hibridación que está presente cuando un
carbono está unido a dos átomos muy bien
y vamos a fijarnos justamente en este
carbono que tenemos aquí y esta es la
molécula del eti no verdad también se le
conoce como acetileno ahora este carbono
está unido tanto a un hidrógeno que
tenemos del lado izquierdo como a otro
carbono que está del lado derecho verdad
así que solo está unido a dos átomos y
digamos que la figura de la molécula del
acetileno se ha determinado que es
lineal tenemos una geometría lineal
también tenemos un ángulo digamos de
este enlace de verdad entre estos dos
enlaces este ángulo es de
aproximadamente 180 grados muy bien así
que por todo esto deberíamos tener una
hibridación distinta para este
para este carbono verdad y digamos para
que podamos tener una distinta geometría
y un ángulo entre los los enlaces
distintos a lo que ya habíamos
encontrado verdad y eso por supuesto
también será distinto para el número de
átomos a los cuales está unido este
carbono así que para hallar un nuevo
tipo de hibridación tenemos que fijarnos
en nuestra configuración electrónica
verdad ok y vamos a ver que para este
esta configuración que ya está en el
estado excitado vamos a ver qué es lo
que va a ocurrir muy bien entonces
tenemos que los carbonos tienen cuatro
electrones de valencia que están
representados justamente aquí tenemos
uno
3 y 4 muy bien y estamos buscando
orbitales híbridos ya que el carbono
puede unirse a dos átomos así que vamos
a tomar un orbital s vamos a promoverlo
vamos a promover por un orbital ese y
ahora sólo vamos a bajar un orbital p
muy bien por supuesto si sólo tomamos un
orbital s y un orbital p entonces nos
quedan digamos por acá tenemos dos
orbitales t muy bien y por supuesto en
cada uno de estos tenemos nuestro
electrón pero lo que va a ocurrir es que
este ya no es un orbital ese ahora es un
orbital esp y lo mismo ocurre para este
otro orbital ahora es un orbital híbrido
esp porque sp pues nuevamente como hemos
visto en los otros casos pues porque
tenemos un orbital ese y un orbital p
verdad justamente de ahí viene esto así
que es a esto a lo que le conocemos como
hibridación
de verdad es la hibridación esp y de
hecho decimos que este carbono de aquí
tiene una hibridación esp verdad y lo
mismo ocurre para este otro carbono es
exactamente igual
ahora vamos a pensar un poquito en cómo
es la forma o la geometría de nuestros
orbitales híbridos es verdad y
recordemos que estos orbitales híbridos
constan principalmente de un orbital ese
que tiene una geometría esférica y un
orbital p verdad que tiene como forma de
doble lóbulo verdad y pues entonces al
tener esto vamos a tener dos orbitales
híbridos que va a tener un lóbulo más o
menos de esta forma y un lóbulo más
pequeño y como hemos estado viendo en
los otros vídeos este lo vamos a omitir
si ahora pensamos por ejemplo en el
porcentaje de características que tienen
estos orbitales híbridos pues podemos
ver que si tenemos dos y uno de ellos
era ese este va a tener un 50% de
características del orbital s mientras
que va a tener un 50% de características
del orbital p y recordemos por ejemplo
que las características del orbital s
para la hibridación sp3 consistían en un
25 por ciento mientras que cuando
hablábamos de hibridación sp2 en
realidad constaban de un 33 por ciento
de las características es así que como
para la hibridación esp tenemos todavía
más características del orbital ese y
estamos hablando de un 50 por ciento
entonces la densidad electrónica de un
orbital es en verdad
la densidad de electrónica de un orbital
ese se incrementa verdad está mucho más
cerca del núcleo para un orbital s que
para un orbital p eso significa que este
lóbulo que tenemos x
este el lóbulo que tenemos por aquí
tiene todavía una mayor densidad
electrónica y más cerca del núcleo
verdad que es una forma en la que
podemos pensar porque estos enlaces
tienden a ser cada vez más más cortos a
medida que aumentamos las
características del orbital es de verdad
en general si incrementamos las
características del orbital s vamos a
tener enlaces mucho más cortos verdad y
eso es porque tenemos un orbital híbrido
mucho más pequeño muy bien así que
regresamos a la figura del acetileno
delete y no ok vamos a tratar de dibujar
esta molécula entonces para hacer para
no estar regresando mucho vamos a
dibujar de nuevo esta estructura de
puntos
y ahí tenemos esta estructura de puntos
muy bien para el acetileno y sabemos que
cada carbono tiene una hibridación esp
verdad entonces cada carbono tiene dos
orbitales híbridos esp entonces vamos a
tratar de dibujar los ok aquí digamos
tengo este carbono y tenemos un orbital
híbrido esp y aquí tenemos otro orbital
híbrido s p entonces déjenme regresar
rápidamente al diagrama que tenemos aquí
arriba necesitamos dos orbitales
híbridos esp verdad aquí tenemos uno y
dos que son los que ya hemos dibujado y
por supuesto cada uno de ellos tiene un
electrón entonces podemos regresar al
diagrama que tenemos aquí abajo y poner
los electrones que están en estos
orbitales híbridos y además tenemos dos
orbitales p
y ahí tenemos el otro verdad y cada uno
de ellos también tiene un electrón
entonces tenemos que poner estos
orbitales p
este orbital p y aquí vamos a tener otro
orbital p muy bien y cada uno de ellos
tiene un electrón y lo mismo tenemos que
hacer con el otro carbono verdad
entonces vamos a poner aquí nuestro otro
carbono vamos a ponerlo por aquí que
tiene un orbital híbrido esp que tiene
el otro orbital híbrido esp y en cada
uno de ellos tiene un electrón y por
supuesto también tenemos que poner los
dos orbitales p que nos faltan verdad
entonces vamos a ponerlo más o menos así
uno de ellos y vamos a poner el electrón
y
el otro orbital p muy bien ahí lo
tenemos y finalmente vamos a agregar los
hidrógenos que vamos a poner en azul
como hemos estado haciendo verdad y es
un hidrógeno en cada uno de esos
carbonos entonces aquí tenemos uno de
estos hidrógenos que sólo tienen un
orbital ese que no está hibridado y aquí
tenemos otro hidrógeno verdad ahí están
los hidrógenos y ya sabemos de hecho
cuando tenemos un traslape de orbitales
que eso corresponde a enlace sigma
entonces como podemos ver tenemos dos
enlaces igna y un tercer enlace sigma
que correspondería a este enlace a este
enlace y a este otro enlace dándonos un
total de tres enlaces sigma para la
molécula del acetileno y en el vídeo de
hibridación sp2 vimos cómo hacer un
enlace y verdad teníamos este traslape
digamos por el costado entonces estos
dos orbitales están trasladando digamos
el costado y se traslapan digamos tanto
arriba como abajo verdad quizás debería
poner esto un poco más acá para que sea
un poco más claro con el otro mientras
que estos dos orbitales
hacerlo un poco más recto este orbital
se traslapa también con este otro
orbital verdad y se traslapan tanto
abajo como arriba verdad vamos a ponerlo
más o menos déjenme hacer una mejor
línea ok y se traslapan digamos también
por aquí
muy bien entonces tenemos estos dos
traslapes por el costado de estos
orbitales lo cual corresponde a dos
enlaces pi entonces si hacemos un
resumen de esto tenemos tres enlaces
sigma y tenemos un enlace tenemos este
corresponde a un enlace pi y el otro
corresponde a otro enlace p entonces
tenemos dos enlaces pi y que en nuestra
estructura de puntos corresponden a
estos dos y recordemos que los enlaces
pi previenen de que podamos tener una
rotación libre alrededor del enlace
sigma verdad entonces para esta molécula
justo como como la que vimos en el
ejemplo anterior
no podemos hallar una rotación libre en
el espacio alrededor del enlace sigma
verdad justo por la presencia de los
enlaces pi y de ahí que tengamos una
figura lineal verdad y de hecho podemos
dibujar la línea
nos define esta molécula verdad
podríamos pensar en esta línea dado por
digamos por lo que estamos poniendo en
líneas punteadas verdades es como la
estructura lineal que tenemos en esta
molécula y también estos enlaces pi nos
dicen algo sobre la longitud del enlace
verdad si nos fijamos en los carbonos
que estoy subrayando con verde verdad
entonces la longitud entre estos dos
carbonos resulta ser de aproximadamente
1.20 angstrom es verdad mucho más corto
o bueno un poco más corto que los que
hemos visto en los vídeos anteriores y
nuevamente esto se debe a que hemos
incrementado las características s de
los orbitales híbridos verdad eso nos
nos garantiza que tenemos orbitales más
pequeños y es una forma de pensar porque
tenemos una distancia de los enlaces
mucho más cortas cuando tenemos en los
triples comparados por ejemplo cuando
tenemos enlaces dobles o enlaces simples
verdad así que esto es mucho lo que
hemos cubierto hasta aquí vamos a vamos
a dibujar la estructura de puntos
nuevamente
esta molécula para ahora utilizar el
concepto del número esférico muy bien
vamos a usar el concepto del número
estético ponemos de nuevo la estructura
de puntos que es este carbono triple
enlace con el carbono y agregamos los
dos hidrógenos muy bien y si nosotros
queremos calcular el número estético el
número estético para este carbono por
ejemplo esto en realidad se calcula como
el número de enlaces sigma que
recordemos que hay sólo dos verdad sólo
tenemos dos enlaces sigma más el número
de parejas de electrones solitarios
alrededor del carbono que en este caso
es cero verdad entonces nuestro número
estético es 2 lo cual nos dice que
necesitamos dos orbitales híbridos que
hacemos de un orbitales y de un orbital
de verdad así que eso es lo que nos dice
este número estético igual a dos así que
por esto es que podríamos pensar que
tenemos una hibridación esp para este
carbono y por supuesto es exactamente
igual para este otro
carbono verdad y así es como utilizamos
el número estético y nuevamente tenemos
una geometría lineal con ángulos de
aproximadamente de 180 grados vamos a
hacer otro ejemplo usando el concepto de
número estético digamos vamos a
considerar el dióxido de carbono aunque
entonces tenemos un carbono que tiene un
doble enlace con un oxígeno y otro doble
enlace con este oxígeno y por supuesto
los oxígenos tienen estos electrones
alrededor de ellos muy bien entonces
nuevamente si queremos calcular el
número estético para este carbono pues
esto será el número de enlaces sigma que
tenemos alrededor de este que en este
caso sólo son dos verdad los enlaces
dobles sólo tienen un enlace sigma y el
otro es un enlace pi y luego sumamos
cero que es el número de electrones
solitarios alrededor del carbono y esto
nos da dos entonces como vimos en el
ejemplo anterior esto nos dice que
podríamos tener una hibridación esp
verdad
está este carbono tiene una hibridación
esp y por lo tanto podemos decir que
tenemos una molécula lineal verdad con
un ángulo entre los enlaces de 180
grados nuevamente el número estético es
una forma muy bonita de de como analizar
la hibridación y también la geometría de
esta molécula ahora en el próximo vídeo
vamos a fijarnos en un par de ejemplos
de moléculas orgánicas que tienen
distintos estados de hibridación